So a video of yours talking of chronic infections need a cause of illness. How do you test for that?
Okay, so testing, so chronic infections can be a cause of illness, but they can be a chronic viral infection,
a chronic bacterial infection, or a chronic
like a spirochet like tick-bord illness infection. So you do, you use different tests for that.
If you thought you had a chronic Lyme or something like that, there is a Lyme PCR test
that we have on our, it's available on our lab store, and if you find information to answer this
question on our, that same course, the chronic disease and autoimmune course.
But you do, you run a Lyme test. So you'd see if you have antibodies,
encourage antibodies to Lyme disease in the cold infection. So Lyme disease technically is
Borrelia, Bernador, for you to grab negative bacteria, but it carries along with a number of different
cold infections. You want to test for all those cold infections as well. If you thought you had a
chronic bacterial infection, which actually is very common, and if, or, and or a chronic viral
infection, I understand you get more than one of these things going on at the same time.
Many times you'll pick those up on standard labs. So I picked those up on standard CBC.
That's a complete blood count with differential. You can see a slightly elevated
white blood cell count. So normal white blood cell count, if you look at a lab, so if you ran a CBC
you'd see a normal white blood cell count. Every lab's normal is a little bit different, but it'd be
about between four and eleven. But really your functional normal for white blood cell count is
really about four point five to seven. Some people would even say six point five. If you have anything
over six point five or seven, you definitely have an infection. Now many times you'll look at past labs
of a person, if you have a history of labs, and they have a past lab white blood cell count that
has been running eight, nine for the past several years. I see that all the time with chronic
lying patients with chronic infection patients see this all the time. So it's not a current infection
door. They have symptoms of a current infection. Take them out. They really do have a current
infection, but they don't have symptoms of like a current hot infection. They don't have a fever,
they're not like ill. They just have not felt well for several years. So they'll have a slightly
elevated meaning above functional normal, but maybe even within the range of lab range. So there'll be
less than eleven, eleven point five, but there'll be above seven. That's a side you have an infection.
Then you could look at the differential of the white blood cell count as you could get an idea
if there's an elevated nutrient fill count versus lymphocyte count, then it's more likely a chronic
bacterial infection. If it's an elevated lymphocyte count and a suppressed nutrient fill count,
it's more likely a chronic viral infection. But quite honestly, I've seen where those who are
normal, or they were in balance, the percentage between the two, because the person had both
a chronic bacterial infection and a chronic viral infection. So it can get a little confusing.
There is some other more specific labs that you can do. Cyrex has an array 11 and array 12,
where you can get into the minutiae of that and see where what it is that we're looking for. So if we
have to, there's different labs that you can run to get into the minutiae of what it is that we're
actually dealing with. But the truth is, many times people are dealing with more than one thing,
so they may have had a suppressed immune system for a period of time, maybe going through
high amount of stress. They're exposed to different viruses or bacteria. Their immune system just
wasn't able to fight that off. In my chronic Lyme course, I actually give some reasons why this happens,
different bacteria can tend to hide in the system. Just like different Lyme bacteria and
colon infections can actually mimic your normal microbiota and hide in the normal microbiota,
so that your immune system doesn't recognize it as an enemy. At worst, a scenario they can go
intracellularly. So viruses go intracellularly normally and they replicate inside the cell
and cause dispulsion of the cell and then it can go outside of the cell and make the person sick
and then it can hide back inside the cell. When bacteria goes inside the cell, it's even worse,
and that's a very common thing. So H-Pyloria is a common bacteria, so is the burguidorope bacteria
from chronic Lyme. So you have to dig into different labs to test what that would be.